I think one of the key trends in 2011 is
the loss of control the international
events are no more shaped by
international institutions institutions
of emerge trap the world war two are all
struggling it's not going to be shaped
by major powers you see the European
Union having to struggle with its own
internal crisis so the you will not be
exporting security you see the United
States with a divided government and you
see China more assertive but not the
dead to shape the world agenda and you
see the other emerging powers also now
coming to the table including at the
Security Council next year with
countries like India Brazil Germany and
Nigeria South Africa on the council but
they want to base at the table they are
right to one that place is there any
consensus on where they would want to
drive the world no and so the weakness
of institutions the divided governments
and the lack of a key consensus I think
that means loss of control and that
means that the world in 2011 will be
much more in a crisis management mode
than in a shaping the world mode it's
more a 19-13 1930s mode let's say that
in 1945